welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day 19
and we're gonna learn how you can invest
like a billionaire
enjoy
[Music]
i'm big on diversification you're very
big on diversity knowing how
knowing how to adversely well is more
important than
almost anything people don't understand
this is that an evergreen principle
yes that's an evergreen principle and
the reason i'm saying that
the way it is it's almost like a casino
making its
money okay okay the way that you do it
is you get an edge
so now when you have to make a bet i've
got to bet against the whole world the
world has
view on something is reflected in the
price so
when i think something is attractive or
unattractive
that means i have to bet against the
whole world and whether that's right or
not
that's difficult i get it right you know
more often than i get it wrong
but i'm going to get it wrong sometimes
and so
when you can take a lot of different
bets
what you can do is like the casino
you'll get your average that your bet
would be
but you'll reduce your risk of one of
those tables not being the table that's
paying off
and so that margin that so i can reduce
my risk without reducing my return
by knowing how to diversify and i'd say
that's particularly true
important for for the people who are
listening your investors
because what they've got to reduce risk
without reducing return
that's right that's the specialty that's
right elaborate a little bit more if you
don't mind on that so reducing risk
without
reducing the return because a lot of
times if i'm
reducing the risk it means my return is
also going lower but you're saying no
we're using it without even reducing the
return
right i mean that's a high paying skill
set to have
it's the most important thing that you
could start off doing
if you have a number of equally
good likely bets but they're
uncorrelated
like the casino you know one table
is going to get me a margin like this
but
take another table and it makes me a
margin like this
but i might have volatility about those
let me take all those investments that i
think will make 10
so that's my return but they're
uncorrelated with each other
that means i'll still get to 10 i don't
lower my 10
but my diversification means i lower my
risk
so i improve my return to risk ratio
ah is that an art that you can teach oh
yeah yeah
i wrote about it in there's a what i
call a section in this book the
holy grail of investing it's like three
pages long
and it explains basically this important
thing because when that epiphany
happened to me and how i would do it
it changed everything by being able to
do that because how old were you
i can improve through diversification i
can
improve my return to risk ratio
by a factor of five so
by diversifying okay
the return relative to the risk i can
keep my returns the same
and reduce my risk to one-fifth
if i know how to diversify well and
that's why i'm explaining it's not all
that complicated it's
simply explained in the book but in any
case that
is the holy grail of investing
okay that's a big thing if you start to
know that that's what you're going for
it changes everything and it's so
important for the average person who's
listening
and let me explain why that is because
the average person who's listening too
many people
think that they can go into this very
difficult zero-sum
game of betting against the consensus
and be right
you know what i mean in other words
investors says i'm gonna go in the
markets i'm gonna make money
betting against the consensus and be
right right because the consensus is
built into the price
okay okay that's what's up so it's think
of it as like going to a horse race
and there's handicaps okay you're not
going to pick the best horse
and you're not going to pick the best
company a terrible company can be a
better investment than a
uh a terrific company a terrible company
could be a better investment just like
the terrible horse
can be a better because the odds that
are
changing like you go into that and that
becomes the long shot
but because the long shot is going to
pay off 25 to 1
right if he comes in that
um you could just as likely bet on the
the long shot
as the leader and it's going to be
equally likely that you're going to make
money right
otherwise you'd otherwise the market
would be doing the opposite
well the market is like that right in
other words if everybody believes that
something's going to be terrific
okay then everybody's betting on it and
it's price is high
so it's not what's best necessarily
it's what's best relative to what's in
the price what's discount
in order for you
um to win in the game like you're going
to go in and pick what's a good
investment
you are pr playing against others
you have to realize that because that's
it's all in the odds it's like when you
go to the track you're going to have to
play against the handicappers
okay so it is very difficult
for you to beat me or to beat others who
are putting 1500 people and
hundreds of millions of dollars into how
to win in that game
right and there's a lot of people and i
find it challenging i find it difficult
so it's difficult to win in that game
it's it's difficult to win in that game
individually by placing the bets it's
difficult to win in that game
it's more difficult to succeed in the
markets
than it is to succeed in the olympics
okay
people but people don't realize that
they think i'm going to go have an
opportunity sure
okay but there are more people trying to
do it in the markets that are trying to
do it in the olympics and so nobody
would say
i'm going to run and compete in the
olympics when you realize how difficult
that is
okay but you can diversify well
anybody could diversify well so if we
look at what the world will be like in
five years or three years or one year
okay like we're coming in the
presidential election
we have all these things going on okay
you want to bet on it
okay wise guy give it a shot that's what
is that is that easy that's what you're
doing okay well the only way i can do it
is i need to diversify my bets well i
wouldn't want to concentrate
on any one of those and i try to i'll
take
like the casino i will take i'll take
that bet
and i'll take this bet and i'll take a
bunch of those bets but for you
as the average investor you're probably
not going to even be able to pick which
horse has got the
the edge relative to the handicappers
okay and so diversification
that is the thing that i would say
particularly for anybody
it is the most important thing it's if
you know how to do that well
so that's why i'm saying you know that
page those couple of pages here was
something i wanted to pass along to you
you'll see a lot of people will say
that's a boring formula or it's an
outdated you know you'll be in the
industry and so
this whole diversification is a boring
formula
et cetera et cetera i'm just trying to
say i went from nothing you asked me
okay my dad's a jazz musician
middle class or low middle class family
uh um i had nothing
other than parents who cared me and i
could go to a good public school
and that was the only thing i had and if
i took that
and i say okay here i am with the
things that is happening over the
markets and making money and
building a business and so on there's
there are a limited number of principles
that i want to pass along to people
because i think if they can get those
principles that that would be extremely
valuable and this is not boring so when
i come back and you say
that ark in life is not boring that was
a very successful
and exciting arc in life and this is one
of those principles
so if you take diversifying well how to
diversify well
please go understand that principle it's
only a couple of pages
please go understand that principle
because when you have savings
and you think how much money do i need
for my kids education
or my retirement or whatever it is and
so on and if you don't know how to do
this well
you're risking a lot and if you do it
well and so on
it produces an enormous amount of
opportunity i should explain
believability weighted decision making
to you if you're sure if you're
interested
ordinarily you're the two ways of making
decisions
pretty much uh there's the boss has
control
and some autocratic autocratic i'll call
that autocratic
takes in everything and then he makes a
decision or
there's democratic pretty much one man
one vote
um but really the best decision making
is believability weighted decision
making and if you think about it first
conceptually
you would say um if you're going to make
a decision of what you have medical
condition
and you're going how are you going to
get that you're going to think who are
the best doctors
consult the experts right consult the
experts but this one knows more and that
one knows more
less and how do you do it and then you
have this triangulation
and then you make that that's kind of
the idea of believability decision
making we have ways of
signing believability that we all agree
are fair that we
each assess each other and we get
certain amount of believability points
so now imagine that you had
believability
your believability on a subject matter
maybe it's investing
maybe it's accounting whatever the
subject is that you have a certain
amount of believability weighted points
and you're together
well those believability weighted points
uh when you say okay what should i make
as a decision now i'm
responsible for something but i ask
everybody else
i and i take a believability weighted
vote i can have a believability weighted
vote
when i have that believability way to
vote vote i really do believe
that it's going to be a better decision
than i would individually make
that's believability weighted decision
making and it's fantastic
when you have independent thinkers in
in order to be successful in the markets
or as an entrepreneur one has to be
um an independent thinker that makes
decisions better than the consensus
decisions that's fair in the markets
the consensus is built into the price
it's beta
yeah so now
you have to bet against the consensus to
make money
therefore you have to be an independent
thinker the best dynamic
is to have a bunch of independent
thinkers now you've got a bunch of
independent thinkers how are they going
to have thoughtful disagreement
and get past those disagreements how we
have done that
is the key to our success i started as
a day trader effectively meaning on the
side i would speculate
in my you know teens and in my 20s an
investor is not a speculator and it's
not a day trader
um and i think that a lot of retail a
lot of normal people the only way they
will close the inequality gap
is because they take it upon themselves
to learn how to become an investor
the government's not going to save them
no law is going to save them
no you know taxation of the rich is
going to save them
they can save themselves and you have to
learn how to invest which is to
put money into the things you care about
and then do nothing well maybe i can
just give you an insight into how
i process any opportunity sure company
random company comes in
uh to the top of the funnel immediately
i'm making a very quick
hopefully it's a decision but maybe
sometimes it's a judgment
um and i'm asking myself does this fit
into my world view or not meaning is it
is it in my circle of confidence and i
have a very simple way of looking at
this
is it going to fix something inequality
that i think is important or is it going
to fix something in climate change that
i think is important those are the only
two things i care about
inequality and climate change under
inequality there's a bunch of stuff
financial equality is important health
care equality is important
education equality is important so it
allows me to organize
a lot of different opportunities um
and i'm trying to figure out is there a
consumer proposition here that's
important for them
does it make something more symmetric
does it take something that was
asymmetric and fix it so that's my first
judgment which is
qualitative that's why whenever i start
my one pagers it's always
what is the strategy and you can read
all of these one pages now
and what you'll get away from them is
the first lens is equality
and or climate change
then i start to do the fundamental work
and you know this is where
i have a real issue with a lot of people
who say that they're value investors
i think that i'm a value blister um the
thing is that when you look up the word
value in the dictionary it doesn't mean
cheap it doesn't mean a cigar but with
two puffs
you know that famous buffett monger club
i think it actually means something that
has value and so then i'm really
thinking about
you know what are the cash flows of this
business how does it create a moat
right meaning in software some
technological way that's hard for people
to
compete with it and then can i get it
for a price
where there's a margin of safety where
if they miss execute for a quarter or if
they have a little hiccup
it's going to be okay because you know
we've got an entry point where
five or ten years from now this thing
will be
five to ten times bigger and that's how
we think about all these things and if
you look at the deals that i've done
they kind of map pretty singularly one
to one to that
um framework a lot of my life quite
honestly just copying things that i see
there's not a lot of original thought
here it truly is not i mean
we can all pretend we're all geniuses
honestly be good copiers
do you know what i'm saying it's the
best thing in the world
like be around high functioning high
quality people
and just copy the [ __ ] that they do
observe the [ __ ] that's you know kind of
crappy and then don't do that stuff
it's not complicated for me
when have you used that best no all the
time
i mean look now it's funny like it's
it's like you know like you have a
surface area of ways to spend your time
now or i do
and you know i'm in this mix now where
we are really scaling up
what we're doing as a business and
i meet these people that to me are so
iconic that they were
sort of like arms length people that are
now sitting face to face
and they treat me like a quasi-peer i
wouldn't say appear but quasi-pure
but what i see is
i see some amazing stuff and i see some
utter dysfunction
in some of the richest most important
people in the world
and i have to decide how am i going to
act
what am i going to embody what am i
copying what am i not copying
and so i get a chance to now
refine my um decision making and
discipline
and it's so that that's how i that's how
it plays i was wondering if you have any
stock tips for any of the students you
know
who are all trying to uh make make a
little living
i didn't think they taught that at
georgetown
they now they the best the best
investment i ever met well
i i bought a book in 1949 by a fellow
named ben graham called the intelligent
investor
i i don't remember what i paid but aside
from what i paid for my two marriage
licenses that was the best investment i
ever made
and uh it's very important
to have the right framework you need you
need
you need to have an approach to
investing that sound and
graham's approach is simple uh
but some people uh adopt to it
and and which i did immediately and and
most people don't
but if you have the right philosophy you
will find opportunities
uh as you go through the next 20 30 40
50 years and
and frankly you're most likely to find
them uh
when in periods like five years ago when
we were having
the panic i mean uh
stocks sell at silly prices from time to
time
most stocks at one time or another sell
at very silly prices
uh and it doesn't take
a high iq to figure out that they're
cheap
but it does take a temperament that's
willing to step
up and actually act i tell people if
they're going in the investment business
if you've got 160 iq
sell 30 points to somebody else because
you won't need it i mean that
that i mean i figured out very early you
don't have to be that smart of this
business which is fortunate
but you do have to have the right
temperament and you have to be able to
ignore
what other people are saying and and
simply look at the facts
and decide is this stock which is
selling it
x worth 2x and occasionally you'll find
things like that and if
when you don't find them you don't do
anything so that's my
generalized stock tip no names the real
test
of whether you would like it as an
investment is whether you would be happy
if it never got quoted again and
just in terms of what the asset did for
you uh
uh but that doesn't i will say this
about gold uh
if you took all of the gold in the world
it would it would roughly make a cube
67 feet on a side so if you took all the
gold in the world we could have a cube
that went down there
67 feet 67 feet high and that would be
the whole thing
now for that same cube of gold
it would be worth it today's market
prices about
seven trillion dollars that's probably
about a third of the value of all the
stocks in the united states so you could
have a
choice of owning a third of all the
stocks in the united states or you could
have a choice of owning a little block
of gold which can't do anything but
kind of shine there and make you feel
like my dessert creases or something of
the sort
now for seven trillion dollars
there are roughly a billion far acres of
farmland in the united states
they're valued at about two and a half
trillion dollars it's about half the
continental united states is farmland
you could have all the farmland in the
united states
you could have about seven exxon mobils
and you can have a trillion dollars of
walking around money
and if you offered me the choice of
looking at
some 67 foot uh cube of gold and looking
at it all day
you know i'm not touching it fondling it
occasionally you know and then saying
you know do something for me and it says
i don't do anything i just stand here
look pretty
and and and the alternative to that was
to have all the farmland in the country
everything cotton corn soybeans seven
exxon mobils just think of that
add a trillion dollars of walking around
money i i
you know maybe call me crazy but i'll
take the farmland and the exxon mobils
you don't need 150 iq to do what i do
thank god
you know well you don't need 140 you
know 135 you may need 115 or something
like that and
and but you do need discipline you have
to wait
until you see the fat pitch to swing at
because
investing is a no-call strike game you
know if i were a baseball player
and i only like pitches two inches above
my navel
you know some guy could learn that and
he could pitch me you know three or four
inches below that and i get called out
on strikes because i never find a pitch
i like
you can get called out on strikes in
baseball you have to
you have to swing at pitches that you
you don't even necessarily like
particularly after the count gets to two
strikes in business
you don't have to swing at anything you
can sit there and the paper says general
motors at 68 or it says general electric
at 115 or so general dynamics at 63.
and if you don't like those prices you
don't have to swing you can wait there
day after day after day after day and
there are no called strikes
now when you swing when you decide to
buy something
then you know if you swing and miss it's
a strike but it's a marvelous game to be
in because there are no
called strikes and you can simply wait
for that one
time in a month or six months or a year
or two or three years when you really
know what you're doing where you like
the price where you like the people
running the business
and then you swing and you only need a
few swings in your lifetime is there a
meaningful distinction to be drawn
between
making money out of investment and
making money out of speculation it's
always a bet isn't it it's always a
gamble no it isn't a gamble there is a
real distinction that basically
it it's subjective but an investment
attitude you look to the
asset itself to produce the return so if
i buy a farm
and i expected to produce eighty dollars
an acre for me
in terms of its revenue from corn and
soybeans and it cost me six hundred
dollars
i'm looking at the i'm looking at the
return from the farm itself i'm not
looking at the price of the farm every
day or every week or every year
on the other hand if i buy a stock and i
hope it goes up next week
to me that's pure speculation ted
williams wrote a book called the science
of hitting and
ended he had a picture of himself at bat
and the strike zone
broken into i think 77 squares
and he said if he waited for the pitch
that was really in his sweet spot
he would bat 400 and if he had to swing
at something on the lower
corner he would probably bat 235
and in investing i'm in a no called
strike business which is the best
business you can be in
i can look at a thousand different
companies and i don't have to be right
on
every one of them or even 50 of them
so i can pick the ball i want to hit
and the trick in investing is just to
sit there and watch pitch after pitch go
by
and wait for the one right in your sweet
spot and if people are yelling swing you
bum
ignore them there's a temptation
for people to act far too frequently in
stock simply because they're so liquid
over the years you develop a lot of
filters and i do know
what i call my circle of competence so i
i stay within that circle and i don't
worry about things
that are outside that circle defining
what your game is where you're going to
have an edge is enormously important as
a general matter is a one piece of
specific finance
financial advice i would say you know
avoid credit cards just forget about
them
uh we're in various businesses that
issue credit cards the american public
loves credit cards but if you start
revolving debt on credit cards you're
going to be paying
18 or 20 percent and you can't make
progress in your financial life going
around borrowing money at 18 or 20
percent
you can make a lot of money by lending
it out at 18 or 20
over time you know if you can find
anybody that's good that
will borrow from you but you don't want
to be on the side of the equation
that's always behind in life uh
you know i was lucky i'd saved about ten
thousand dollars by the time i got out
of school that ten thousand dollars was
really worth millions i might have
earned later on because after you get a
family and everything the
expenses roll in but but those were my
tools to work with but it was only
because i was ahead of the game
if you're behind the game by ten
thousand dollars at some point and
paying 18 or 20
percent interest on it you will never
you know you'll never get out of it
so the trick i've got a partner that
says
all i want to know is where i'm going to
die so i'll never go there you know
and uh and that's true in financial
matters
as well you want to figure out where you
don't want to be
uh ahead of time and avoid that and i
get about a dozen letters a day
from people who are having terrible
problems and there are two reasons why
they have terrible problems
one is a number of them have had health
problems of some sort i mean they have
really been hit by some or somebody in
their family has been hit by some kind
of catastrophic
illness and that is a you know it's a
terrible thing to happen to any family
and they get in they run up bills they
can't pay and and
really only society can solve that one
uh
uh in terms of protecting people against
that that's just plain bad luck
but the other one is from people who run
up credit card debt
and they're facing bankruptcy or they've
been through bankruptcy once before
and they owe a whole bunch of money and
they can't they can't even pay the
interest let alone pay any principal
and half of my letters come from people
like that and that that that problem is
avoidable
catastrophic illness is not but but uh
credit card debt is something you bring
on yourself and
it's way better it's way easier to stay
out of trouble
than to get out of trouble financially
and and uh i will guarantee you if you
run a big credit card that
you will be in trouble uh probably the
rest of your life
in terms of uh your financial situation
on the other hand if you get ahead of
the game
uh even it's on a very modest scale
so that money is coming in from
investing
and you're you're you people owe you
money or equities owe you ownership
uh you'll be way out of the game
compared to paying it uh
being always being paying your creditors
every month
so my advice to you is uh if you can't
pay for it
don't buy it when you sold micro
solutions for a couple million dollars
um i read the six million don't push it
down i got a couple million
but that's that's nothing right compared
to now it's a lot trust me
but you took that money and then you
invested it into
other technology stocks that you knew
and then you took that and then
went from broadcast.com and then boom
you know right everything
what were those stocks that you invested
in so we teach our kids
um kind of the peter lynch adage invest
in what you know
yeah and i think you took and that's
exactly what i did i mean look i spent
seven years um installing local area
networks writing software um
doing wide area networks and so i knew
what a router you know which companies
routers worked and didn't work
which which companies bridges and
software worked and didn't work
um which products were selling um which
products weren't
and so i i used that to my advantage
because back
back then it was a little bit easier
because there weren't as many people
there weren't as many analysts
covering everything yeah right and so
i was all these huge hedge fund hedge
funds once they saw that i was killing
it
they were like okay we're going to talk
to this guy and literally took my
trading
experience i was making 8 500 a year and
created a hedge fund out of it and oh
yeah and then we just immediately sold
it so it turned out really well
um but i did that now and i'm telling
you
the peter lynch experience is going to
be interesting in terms of okay where do
you shop what do you do
what websites you go to but if you
take the time to learn computer vision
neural networks and everything
that's what that's how all the decisions
are go a lot of decisions are going to
be made but all decisions are going to
be influenced
and so if you really want to get to that
point you know if you look at some of
the hottest stocks right now
nvidia amd they're just
they're blowing up because of their
ability to create processors
that are geared towards um towards
artificial intelligence and and
supporting the data centers
if you look at what's happening with
amazon you know
i own a lot of amazon stock um because
they are the most advanced in using all
these things i've been talking about
you know netflix you know they started
10 years ago
by using um their you know
their versions of artificial
intelligence back then to try to
determine what's the best way to help
guide people to through choosing content
yeah through the whole discovery they
had a million dollar contest
and so you know artificial intelligence
is going to eat the world and so
the peter lynch approach is great but
you have to
um you have to be where the decision
yeah you have to understand that right
it's just it's which is not an easy no
and plus the other problem is
there's a lot fewer companies going
public these days
right back when we went public 20 years
ago there were 9 000
um companies that were public now
there's under 4
000 and so there's more money chasing
fewer choices
which is good on in some respects but
you know it's and it's good because all
that money helped push helps push the
indexes up
right lots of money fewer stocks you
know
so you don't have as many choices um
but it's bad in that there aren't as
many new companies coming out
where you can say okay you know so and
so is going public i know that company
most other people don't
and that might give me an edge in my
investing right your ubers and your
airbnb yeah
yeah and snapchat right snapchat's
supposed to go public airbnb and uber
and let me okay so let's talk about
big-time screw-ups in investing yeah
yeah
so there's a guy named travis clonic
right and he had a company
called red swoosh yeah and i invested in
it and we sold it we made a little bit
of money his next company he emails me
he's got this thing called uber cab and
he's like you should invest in this mark
i'm like i like it it's a great idea
you're going to run into some resistance
from all the
the taxi cab companies and all the
transportation folks in different cities
are going to hate you so you know i like
the idea but i don't like the way you're
pricing it
never heard back from them again now
that's my problem with travis personally
but
obviously it turned into uber and so
sometimes you make it and sometimes you
miss them
if you want to be rich the first thing
you should do
is pay off your credit cards right
if you have a payday loan if you have a
loan pay it off
because that's the boat anchor that's
going to hold you back
they're merciless no mercy
right there's no upside to you look i
get i get how difficult it is
i mean i've been there where i've come
home and the lights are out
and i've had to go down to the utility
company and explain why
this new account that i just opened up
and this check is going to clear even
though the last five haven't
right or when you know you look at your
phone and it's a bill collector
and look it's not always easy but
at the same time going and trying
you've gotta there's
there's just no way to get over that
hump by taking a payday loan or a high
interest rate loan
or prepaid credit card with a high
interest rate
it's it's really tempting and you think
to yourself well if i just do this
i know i can work my way through to pay
it off and get to the next level
and as someone who's had their tears
their amex their visa
their mastercard all cut up in front of
them right
it's just it's it's the biggest boat
anchor that you could ever ask for when
it comes to
your life or starting a business i had a
lot of friends of mine try to talk me
out of
starting a rocket company because they
thought it was crazy and what friend of
mine made me watch a video of rockets
blowing up
[Laughter]
and you know there were just lots of
people thought it was a really crazy
idea and there was some people that had
tried to start rocket companies not
succeeded
and they try to talk me out of it and um
but the thing is that
but the premise for talking out of it
was well we think you're going to lose
the money that you invest i was like
well um
that was my expectation anyway so i
don't really mind if i lose you know i
mean
that might but i mean it's not it's not
like
i was trying to figure out the rank
ordered best way to invest money right
on that basis um you know chose space
right i felt like that's you know i
thought wow you weren't looking at like
money money market bonds triple a bonds
rocket company you weren't like do real
estate yeah yeah you know
uh invest in shoemaking anything um
and whoa space is the highest roi yeah
that's that is not what i there's no no
it wasn't the primes
um i just thought that it was important
that humanity expand beyond earth and
we weren't doing that so maybe there was
something i could do to kind of spur
spur that on our strategy is to buy
super high
quality dominant uh companies that can
withstand
a pandemic or a dramatic movement in
interest rates that are not particularly
exposed to the economy
uh so you know who the president is it's
not something that we would make a bet
one way or another on the portfolio
our principles are basically one invest
in simple predictable free cash flow
generative
dominant companies with large barriers
to entry that are in high returns on
capital
that have limited exposure to extrinsic
risk we can't control
strong balance sheets don't need access
to capital to survive have excellent
management good governance
sounds logical um but you know
occasionally
we've diverged and there's uh those
times you know
there's a certain discipline that comes
with investments and there always seems
to be a
countervailing quality that caused us to
diverge
but in really each case we've
compromised on business quality or
complexity
we've been harmed from an investment
standpoint if you're passive you can
feel like the market's patsy and if
you're active you can actually
create some value and i think it's a lot
more interesting than just picking
securities you know we bought a stake in
chipotle at a time where the company was
struggling a few years ago
we put a few directors on the board we
recruited a new ceo named brian nickel
it's completely turned around the
company the stock is you know almost
tripled
in in the midst of a crisis uh and it
just tells you that you know
that's a lot more fun and it's a lot
more profitable and i would say bet
good for a lot more good for america
than just simply being a passive stock
picker
you were starting your own company but
what expertise did you have to start
your own company in the business world
i had no expertise okay um
and there was really no reason
to give me any backing
fortunately my first foray was in silver
in 1993 and the zeitgeist was that
silver was going to go down to two
dollars because digital film would
supplant silver halide
um i believed that people got the
analysis wrong and that silver had a
better chance of going back to 50.
so i put my money on silver options
and silver went from three and a half to
five and a half dollars in
relatively short order and i made enough
money
to decide that i didn't want to do that
anymore but i would take
all that money and put that when buying
an option on a silver property
well let me make sure i understand uh
where did you get the money to buy the
options
i started with ten thousand dollars okay
so i had you know a little bit of
savings
and turned that into hundreds of
thousands of dollars
and then put the money on a um
on a property in idaho um
and i realized around that time that i
really didn't have very much competition
and so i took whatever money i had and i
went to peru and bolivia
and mexico and i would put down options
on these properties
after a certain period of time i found
that i had as interesting a portfolio
of option properties as any existing
silver company
and i knew that even though i wasn't
ready for prime time
even though the story was
a little bit flaky and delusional a new
york based financial type with no
background in engineering
or geology starting a mining company
i kept it low-key but i was introduced
to george soros and he and his brother
paul
invested in me and how old were you at
this time
i was 32
33 okay and you were married then
i was engaged gage and did your fiance
say
what do you do for a living oh no no no
she was instrumental
in the entire process when i had the
the vision of uh buying silver mines
um it was in the middle of the night
and she was at nyu she'd left the
israeli air force and
was studying at nyu um
and apparently at three o'clock in the
morning i sat up in bed
and said please write this down so i
don't forget it buy silver mines
and so the next day daphne said to me by
the way last night
you told me to write down buy silver
mines so i'm reminding you
but i'm also going to add this that is
so sexy
and so i went to the silver business wow
so
she has unerring um insight
okay so how did it work out i found
that um it suited my aptitudes to take
that money
and buy assets
and hold those assets having a
historical bent
allowed me to see the market through the
prism of history
and so when you see these cycles
and you understand human psychology and
fear and greed
the history gives you a great
perspective
and so if you own the assets and you
don't go into
debt it really becomes a function of
time before you become fashionable again
and we made a huge discovery in bolivia
and that's where the fortune originated
i started studying because i love real
estate i'm like i need to buy real
estate the cash flows
not real estate what
real estate is going to cash flow today
next month
next year and 10 years from now
apartments
[Music]
what do you think since 1945
the rents in america have gone up since
world war ii
look at how many recessions we've had
between 1945 and 2017.
at 70 years and rince did this the whole
time
it's a graph ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
you don't stop you don't stop 50-year
trends
you don't stop 50-year trends okay so
it leads me down to what apartments
right gives me
apartments and it leaves me at mobile
homes leaves me in storage
i need to focus on one of these because
i'm a focused person i'm not going to
try to do everything
so i started looking at apartments can i
understand apartments first thing i ever
bought was a single family home i put a
renter in if you know my story i put a
renter in it renter moved out
i was like oh that doesn't work sold it
got rid of it i said i'll never do that
again what did i do wrong
one door one door okay if you're taking
notes and you want to go do this
yourself i'll help you do it yourself by
the way you don't have to invest with me
okay never buy one door ever
you want to buy lots of doors the more
doors the better
the more the number of units the most
important number in real estate
the single most important number and
brandon will talk to you about this
tomorrow in
any business the most important number
is the number of in this case units
in a business it would be volume it
would be it would be
it could be square footage it's going to
be huh
it would be how many times can you
multiply that unit times
and the bigger you can get that number
that's why netflix works facebook works
amazon works because these people are
trying to scale that
your bank money right now is earning
point zero zero
two five percent my real estate's earned
20
if you have no place to go you see when
i was 26 years old i was broke 27 i was
broke 28 i was broke 29 i was broke
30 i was broke you know why because i
take the 5 grand and i push it off to
the side and i was broke again
hustling to get another five grand why
because i knew where i was going
i was going here i'm like i'm gonna be a
millionaire dude ain't nobody gonna take
this deal from me and i am not gonna
wait till i'm 90 years old to get the
million bucks
right by the time i'm 33 years old i had
1 million 125
127 bucks in a damn account 1 million
125
127 33 years old and i started with no
money at 25
how i got the 5 000 i don't need to go
buy something yet
i got to add that every year now i need
to learn how to get that money to grow
20 a year it'll take me 20 years
to get it done how did i get it done in
eight years
i must have either added money or earn
more than 20
and it was a combination of both how do
you do that
you don't do it at your job you can't go
you can't be a waitress making
you know forty thousand bucks a year and
all of a sudden make twenty percent more
it's your job you can't like it just
doesn't you can't just all of a sudden
say
i'm 20 better give me 20 more money and
even if you could you'll do it one time
not every year
francisco it cannot be such a good
cameraman that he's like
hey dude look give me a 20 raise this
year all right
can he do it again next year sooner or
later i'm gonna be like
tapping out dawg okay your photos aren't
that good
i mean they were good but now they're
getting expensive
when i read these books in my 20s about
successful people
they all they all owned real estate all
the successful people
the the rockefellers the oil barons the
railroad guys
they all ended up with real estate car
dealers car dealers don't make money
selling cars just so you know
car dealers make money because they pay
for their real estate
they rent it back to the store and they
end up with a facility that pays them
forever
for for acres and acres of real estate
just so you know
every car dealer in america gets rich
because of their real estate not just
because of their cars
the cars pay for the real estate
how many of you know a rich car dealer
okay mcdonald's
ray kroc he he didn't he didn't have the
recipe
he got control of mcdonald's because
of real estate jeff bezos today
in every major city in america right now
is making real estate place
so you're here because you already
understand that
i understood it and i started writing
this down 20 units or more
the guy invests 5 000 he's got 5 000
in the bank another guy's got 50 grand
in the bank and another guy's got 500
000 okay all three of these people
invested money with me
this is cliff this is dave and this is
jennifer
okay cliff sent me five grand dude it
was his last five grand it was as hard
for him to do this
as this guy to do that do you understand
okay
this guy earns i don't know he's gonna
earn 300 bucks a year
this guy's gonna earn three thousand
dollars a year this guy's gonna earn
thirty thousand dollars a year
but they all had to start with this
they all start with five thousand
dollars everybody starts with five
thousand dollars including jennifer
right here
she's got a five just another zero
all of them had to make a decision
should i keep the money this is where
the opportunity comes in
you got to think in terms of opportunity
costs okay
is my money better in the bank or is my
money better in an asset that
ad that can grow over time okay do i buy
a watch
okay do i buy something stupid
it is beautiful but it's stupid let's
keep it real
stupid is as stupid does
and that ladies and gentlemen is stupid
paddock
okay however the reason the way i bought
the paddock was because the real estate
that i buy
not this real estate okay i already
distributed these people the real estate
i
invested in sent me a little check check
when i started my business i'd get money
and i'd save it i'd get money and i'd
save i'd get money and i'd save it and i
didn't spend money in marketing and
branding so when i was writing the 10x
rule i'm like dude why am i not bigger
than i'm
i've been busting my ass working so hard
i've been pushing and shoving
i have the best products of any anybody
in my space i know i have the biggest
the biggest platformer products and the
best products
why why why are other guys kicking my
ass
and i'm like dude you haven't reinvested
the money in marketing and branding
right i was not spending money i look at
the mattress guy in boston i look at the
car dealer in boston
herb chambers outspent everybody crushes
the the mattress guy
outspends everybody the my the my pillow
guy on on tv
he who knows what he spends he might
spend 100 million dollars a year in
advertising to get a billion dollar and
i'm like oh my god
dum-dum you didn't market and you didn't
advertise so this month we'll spend
probably a million dollars
on advertising on advertising people ask
me every day hey what's the best thing
you've done in your career
the best two things i've done in my
career maybe three things one find her
number two work hard
even the things i didn't want to do but
the third thing the game changer in my
life
in addition to her and working hard was
taking the money that i made
and investing it in real estate income
producing
non-speculative real estate that
produces positive cash flow
see these planes behind me these are
wealthy people
either there they're wealthy people or
they're very wealthy companies
they keep investing back in assets that
pay them
a billionaire once told me grant the
best company the best investment is a
company that produces
income that's what apartments do that's
what office builders do
and when you combine them in the right
locations
it's like making an investment in your
wife it's like make an investment in
your family or your mom and your dad
you know those are things that are going
to be there for you that you can depend
on so look find
real estate that you know is in a good
location
that's highly desirable today it will be
10 years 15 and 20 years from now
if people can rent from you you can
provide them with a great place to live
and it's going to provide you with
wealth in the future that's how all
these people
they either started in real estate or
their money
ends up in real estate and that's what
we've done the third most successful
thing i've done in my career is how i've
decided to use the money that i worked
hard for
the money that i've accumulated the
money i work for it is the single only
thing that separates me from other
people that have worked hard
and found the right life i took that
money
and i invested in hard assets that
appreciate over time and then pay me
and then we can waste a little money we
can go on a plane we can fly private we
can go on dumb vacations
we can buy stuff that goes down in value
with assets that lived in value and pay
us every month
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i wanna know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free
in the first line of the description
below and if you're enjoying this
billionaire mindset series give me a
hashtag billionaire mindset in the
comments below
so i can celebrate you i hate spending
money until i'm making money
i think this is how so many people end
up going broke you take all the money
you have
pour it into your business and because
you don't know what you're doing yet
you fail and end up losing everything
taking that one shot
may mean you're in debt for the rest of
your life i want you to take a smarter
path
so i look at my youtube channel as an
example i've started this channel 10
years ago it's crazy just over 10 years
ago what a crazy ride
but when i started it i had nothing and
i didn't want to spend my money
on hiring a bunch of people and
investing into gear and equipment and
everything else
and so i started by just asking a friend
of mine mark who's been a long time
friend of the channel
if he would come and film me he had a
video production company at the time
he said mark can you come and film me
for one episode and he did and he came
in and he filmed me
and it was a lot of work and a lot of
editing afterwards
but he did it because he was a buddy of
mine but he wouldn't do
every video like that and so i had to
find other ways i had to
borrow equipment from my friends and
when i couldn't borrow their camera
anymore
i used the i want i want to pull for my
cell phone but
this didn't exist 10 years ago i didn't
i didn't have this capability 10 years
ago
i used whatever phone i had whatever
camera i had these tiny little things i
don't know if you remember the flip cam
that i would just prop up on on a desk
in front of me
on a bookcase and it would tilt and so
the video itself would be
a little bit looking like it was moving
because it wasn't it wasn't fully stable
sitting there on the shelf
i had sold my business i had made some
money i had another successful business
my website had eight people on my team
but i don't want to spend money until
i'm making money i don't think that's a
healthy practice
maybe i'm a little too uh risk averse
maybe i care too much about protecting
my capital i don't know there are some
people
who go in and they they take out a huge
loan invest everything they have
and and sometimes they hit sometimes you
hit
that's that's the appeal that's the
attraction sometimes it's going to hit
but most of the time it's not and i
would rather at the beginning of
anything
put my heart my energy my hustle my time
my passion
my creativity into something not
investing my resources by investing my
resourcefulness
to see if i can start building something
and so with youtube
i did everything myself at the beginning
did all the editing all the research all
the in front of the camera behind the
camera
everything i brought some friends on
where i could to help me borrow gear use
their time
where i could until i got to the point
where
i could afford to hire somebody and the
first person i hired was a part-time
editor
because i was certain to make some money
for my youtube channel instead of
pulling money from
my bank account or from a friend or or
taking out a loan or an investor
i put my energy my hustle my time into
something
and when i started getting the result
then i poured that money back into the
business to start hiring a part-time
editor
who then became a full-time editor who
then became you know researchers and
other editors and
and people managing my community and
we've got this team now 24 people
but that's how it started here's the
danger with so many businesses
you start a business you you take out a
big loan
you mortgage your house you take out
everything in your savings account
and then it doesn't work out but also
you may not be interested in it
there's so many entrepreneurs who
started a business who want to be in the
t-shirt business and then you order 10
000 t-shirts to get the price break and
you sell 80 of them
and now you've got thousands of t-shirts
sitting in the basement or you buy all
this gear of tripod and microphone and
and light behind me there and a camera
and lens and all of this fancy stuff
and then you make four videos that's too
often what happens with so many ideas
and so you don't know if this idea that
you're going down
will actually be the idea or not you
don't know if you're gonna love somebody
until you get into the relationship
right you don't know if the thing is
going to work or not
and so the best way to do it is to go
and start testing not go and drop
tons of money potentially being in debt
for the rest of your life
on a guess on i wish this could happen
right and i think too many people end up
making a huge financial decision
and then it prevents them from making a
second if you end up in crippling debt
for the rest of your life that makes it
really hard to go off and start again on
your own it's not impossible
but you're stacking the odds against you
and so instead of making stupid
financial decisions from the get
instead invest your heart your
resourcefulness your energy the people
that you love the people you look up to
all started with less than what you
already have right now
if they can do it so can you you just
have to feel that it's possible
and start chasing down your dreams so
i'm going to give you a three-step
process to take that
idea you've got and start with zero
money step number one is break your big
vision down
what is your big vision we as
entrepreneurs
love having big visions it's amazing
it's the best we're gonna change the
world i love it
yes and you gotta start small
you think big and you start small that's
the key
that's the process you don't just think
big and start big
you don't think big and then raise a
hundred million dollars and boom
you're off changing the world everybody
you've looked up to started smaller
right and so you break your big vision
down i'm not asking you to lower your
standards and i'm asking you to not
dream big because that that big dream
is gonna be a thing that will carry you
through when when you're hopeless when
you don't know what to do when you feel
like everything's against you
that big dream will be the thing that
saves you and
you need to start smaller so you take
that big dream that utopia that you want
to build you want to change the way
something's done
and then break it down into what's the
smallest step that i can do right now
step number two is ask yourself what's
the fastest way to making money
making money is important i think people
have a messed up view on money
money is important even if you're a
charity money's important money has to
be in your top five it's not number one
but it's got to be in your top five and
so what in your big vision
as you break it down what's the fastest
way to start making money off this thing
it's an important question to ask i'm
not asking you to sell your soul and do
something you don't want to do
i'm not asking you to do something only
because of the money i don't think
that's
going to be a recipe for success you
have to chase down things that you love
doing what you love doing with where
there's an opportunity people pay you
for
that's the start of a business but in
this big vision of yours
some paths will take a lot longer to
realize and some paths
can be realized right away an example
start a service-based business instead
of product
product takes research takes development
takes time manufacturing costs
all of that shipping lots there's lots
built into that services business is
just your time
start there even if your long term
vision is to be up here
start here start making money because
when you can start making money
when you can afford to quit your job
when you can get out of survival
mentality where you don't know where
your next meal is going to come from or
how you're going to pay the rent
when you can start to build a team and
have people around you who are
contributing their skill sets to allow
you to go off and do the thing that you
have michael jordan level talent at
right when you start building that kind
of momentum
man it feels great and allows you to
build a real business
and so ask yourself within within the
bubble of what you want to build
what's the fastest way you can start
making money and then number three is
who can help get you there
you don't have to be a one-man army all
the time if you have nobody around you
who support you if
the people only around you are trashing
on you hating on you great than a
one-man army or one warming army and you
will will this thing into existence
you're gonna make it happen
but you don't have to be on an island
most of the time there are people who
are willing to help you
with advice with guidance with their
time with their
support with their resources with their
materials my friend mark came in and he
filmed me
on an off day for him now i had to
settle for the time that he had opened
great my next friend then let me his
camera and i use that for my next video
right you don't have to be a one-person
show
whatever is holding you back think about
the gap between where you are where you
need to be
who can help get you there resources
time connections
ideas opinions thoughtfulness all those
things can help you get to where you
need to go
if you reach out and ask you will never
lose in life if you have valuable skills
you won't lose your house you won't lose
your car you won't lose your clients if
you have a skill that brings people
value
the economy can collapse the algorithms
can change
but as long as you have a skill that
solves problems for people
you will be safe so i'm seeing this a
lot in the youtube world now
i have a new course out helping people
get to a million subscribers on youtube
we can link up the description there
if you want in and people are saying
well should i still do youtube is it too
late like
youtube won't be here in five years or
ten years or maybe it's gonna be the
next thing that should hop on
it's not about the platform like right
now it's winning the platform that is
currently winning
you need to crush it right like youtube
should be your home if you're trying to
make an impact you're trying to be a
thought leader you have a message to
spread youtube has to be your number one
place it just has to be
right now otherwise you're not making a
smart decision but whether youtube is
still around in 20 years
five years doesn't matter because the
skill set that you
learn you can take anywhere the ability
to communicate
you could take to any platform you could
take to the next thing i don't
anticipate youtube still being around in
20 years but my ability to make videos
talking to a lens that's not gonna go
away that can serve me for life right
whether that's
vr evan or hologram evan you know coming
into your living room that's
that's gonna be me that's gonna be
amazing i'm pumped i look forward to it
any algorithm change that people are
freaking out about anybody who's
complaining about
the economy going down or the algorithm
changing you've already lost that's a
losing mindset
when i was first starting my youtube
channel i always saw the algorithm as a
chance to win
right you should see if you're a small
creator on any platform
youtube instagram anything and the
algorithm shifts
that's your greatest advantage you
should be cheering you should want more
algorithm changes
if you look at a traditional established
boring market uh it's hard to win real
estate could be hard to win
right financial markets can be hard to
win it's not that it's not possible it's
just hard to win because there's a lot
of people who have
who have decades of experience and no
more than you and it's hard to close
that gap of experience
with social media with youtube every
time there's a big algorithm change the
people who are experts at the last thing
they're crying instead of adjusting
that's how you win
that's how you get ahead of them that's
how you become the top dog
is because you're gonna go learn the new
algorithm when everybody is
wishing and hoping that the old
algorithm comes back and this happens
for every platform it happened for
facebook every time they changed your
algorithm or updated the
the feed and what was shown there people
always freak out and complain
and they sign they want petitions and
like let's go back to what it used to be
don't sign those petitions don't jump on
that bang when that is loser thinking
never
ever ever ever ever ever ever do that
it's loser thinking and that's how most
people think
that's the mindset shift that i want to
make for the collective but more
importantly for you
that whenever there's a big change
embrace it go all in on it learn it
that's how you're going to leapfrog
everybody else so the faster the rate of
change the more you should be cheering
i still get pumped for an algorithm
change me i mean now i'm at now i'm
closer to the top right i mean
i don't know what the top is i got 2
million subscribers and 300 million
views and all these channels
i still love it anytime an algorithm
change comes out i'm still pumped train
yourself like a change is coming i'm
pumped
get excited because there's still people
who are ahead of me or even the people
below me that i'm competing with
for for attention and for space if
they're sitting there complaining about
how it's changed and they're dropping in
their views awesome
i'll pick up those views because i'm
going to learn what the new algorithm is
all about
same thing with the economy when the
economy crashes everybody who's
complaining about how it used to be
they're not going to win it's comforting
to join a club and wish things to be how
they used to be but we're not going back
to that
so the faster you realize that and make
improvements the faster you can learn
and actually build a great business
some of the greatest businesses in the
world were built in recession in
depression
that could be you if you decide to be
let's hop back to skills for a second i
look at
jake paul logan paul they started on
vine right vine was
was their claim to fame they had tons of
success in making these super short
videos
vine gets shut down right boom gone this
is don't put all your eggs in one basket
i think that's loser thinking too it's
loser thinking
they went all in on vine and and then
vine got shut down oh no
what did they do they moved to youtube
instead of crushing it millions of
subscribers look at their growth on
youtube
over the past i don't know two years
three years blew up
why they didn't just come out of nowhere
they had the skill set
they had the skill set that they learned
from doing the thing
right the skill set to make a good video
they then brought to a new platform if
youtube goes away
you're learning the skill set of how to
communicate how to make great videos
that
whatever comes next people are freaking
out about
the ftc coming in and cop on youtube
okay so if kids aren't
able to get content on youtube where
they're gonna go go be there
instead of trying to fight what is
already happening
go be at the place where the kids are
going to be
embrace the change that's where you
that's where you can win when everybody
else is fighting and angry and screaming
and yelling and complaining and wishing
it used to be or quitting the platform
and
getting upset go be where they're gonna
be it's it's easy it's a simple win
most people don't have that mindset it's
why most people lose my most businesses
can't evolve most most businesses shut
down it's people
very rarely transition from one platform
to another from one business to another
even though they have the skill sets and
capabilities to do so because they don't
have the mindset to do so
people who crushed myspace very few of
them are still around
on different platforms looking at look
at hollywood the rock is doing it
will smith is doing it moving from
hollywood films to youtube
where's brad pitt where's george clooney
like they're in a dying industry
they should be embracing youtube they
don't want to they have the skills they
have the skills it's transferable
you don't think george clinton could
come in and crush youtube if you wanted
to
of course he could calling you out
george clooney let's go
make it happen right so it's about
picking up the skill set that will keep
you safe in any environment
but it's also having a mindset to follow
through and try the new things instead
of complaining about the changes that
are currently happening
so how can you do it i'm going to give
you a three-step process that i think
will help
step one is make sure your actions map
to your missions this will help you
determine what skill set you need
what are your ambitions what do you want
to accomplish what do you want out of
life there's so many ways to win
you know if you've gone through the who
why how process you know what your
purpose is you know what you're trying
to accomplish you've
you've read built a survey you can't
read it yet still in pre-order but
you understand the concept you figure
out your purpose great to actually go
off and accomplish it
what are the skill sets that you
actually need what are the skills that
you need to develop even if you suck at
it if you're not naturally good at it
i'm
introverted i'm not naturally good in
front of the camera it took me
six thousand videos to get here right i
got better with practice and repetition
and dedication
hard work and all of that you can too
what are the skill sets that you need to
acquire
to get the life that you want and then
you can start working on them
so first step is figure out how do you
map your actions to your ambitions
second step is to learn to tell yourself
that it's the best it's the best
it's the best every time something
negative is happening to you
the economy is crashing and algorithm is
changing a new competitor comes in
something something negative is
happening
you tell yourself it's the best this is
the best this is my chance
to prove to myself and the world what
i'm made of
when an algorithm changes and you say
it's the best
you're going to find a new solution if
you sit there and complain and get
negative and toxic you're not going to
find a new solution
the best part of saying it's the best is
it shifts your mindset
from one of complaining and lack of
resourcefulness to one of
ultimate resources to be able to say i'm
gonna go solve this thing
let's go it shifts your mindset so many
people get stuck
in the negativity even if you're an
entrepreneur and you're positive and
optimistic and
have great hopes for the future where
you want to go if you spend all this
time and energy building up this thing
and it gets taken away from you it's
really hard to say this is the best
but that's what you need to do because
otherwise you spend the rest of your
life
living off of past glory to say well
this is what i used to be and it was all
taken away from me and now life sucks
like you want the next 40 years of your
life to be
thinking like that no it's the best
the economy crashes the best you're
gonna crush it
algorithm changes is the best you're
gonna crush it new competitor comes in
it's the best
you're gonna crush it right
you grow through difficult times you get
better through a difficult time you
don't want to do the same thing over and
over and over and over again that's
boring that's photocopying your life
that's not what you want
you want to grow you want to progress
self-confidence self-love
all of it comes from doing difficult
things by telling yourself that when
that difficult thing comes
it's the best this is my chance to rise
up
and show myself and the world what i'm
capable of
as opposed to saying this sucks and
sitting in negativity
all day all week all month all year all
decade
and step number three is understand that
the quantity leads to the quality
we figured out what our skill is that we
want to get good at right we understand
that it's the best that when other
people are complaining we're gonna rise
up and improve our skills and get better
at the thing because that's how we're
gonna win
and now number three is the practice the
daily grind the constant improvement
i've done six thousand videos is how i
got better at this the thing that you
wanna get great at
you have to do a lot of you're gonna
suck at the beginning you're not gonna
have any quality that's okay
that's great it's the best right but
then through repetition
through practice through daily hustle
attacking the thing the thing that you
love doing even though other people see
it as work and torture
you love it you're getting better at it
that's how you're gonna improve your
skills
every skill set is possible to acquire
it's just a skill doesn't mean you suck
as a human just means you don't have the
skill set yet
how do you get the skill set by
practicing the quantity leads to the
quality and so back to point number one
of your actions mapped to your ambitions
how much are you practicing you want to
acquire the skill set how much time are
you actually spending on that skill set
you want to be a great editor great how
much time are you spending editing want
to be a great piano player how much time
you spending piano
right you might have some natural
ability for it awesome
and if you don't i had no natural
ability to be good in front of the
camera
go back and watch my first videos you'll
see you'll see how much i sucked
no natural ability zero this took a long
time
practice dedication hard work
right action snap to your ambitions by
putting the quantity that leads to the
quality
how much are you doing show me your
calendar show yourself your calendar
pull up your calendar look at your next
week look at your next month that skill
that you want to acquire that's going to
save you
from the recession from the algorithm
change that's going to bring people
value that skill that you need to
acquire it's going to pay you
how much time you spend in developing it
and if it's not a lot if it's not
sometime every day you got to change
your mindset you got to change your
calendar you need to change your actions
because right now if that's you
your actions are not mapping to your
missions i want you to win you need to
get the skill sets that's the path
if you want to sign up for the entire
billionaire mindset series for free
and get the companion bonus pdf calendar
check the link
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there